these people have been waiting for days
to be allowed inside this temporary
refugee camp in Adana in southern turkey
they're Syrian and have been living in
this country for seven years
but the earthquakes last month left them
homeless
says he and his family have nowhere to
go
the second earthquake destroyed our
house we left our house with children
without any of our belongings so we've
come to this camp where syrians stay I
believe there's enough space in the camp
but we've been living on the streets for
14 days now
Turkish authorities did not reply to our
questions on why these families were not
allowed inside
since the Civil War started in Syria
turkey adopted an open door policy
towards syrians fleeing the conflict
there are now more than 4 million
syrians in the country many are living
in camps where they have shelter food
health care and then education
but over time many Turks started to
rescind the support given to Syrian
refugees by the Turkish state
there's widespread need for food shelter
and basic Services all around the areas
affected by the earthquake in turkey and
that has increased the anti-refugee
sentiment in the country there are many
who would like to see the refugees leave
hundreds of people are living in this
tense City in the center of gaziantev
UE is one and she is angry she says
she's living in a tent with five other
families among them a premature baby
all syrians have tents but we Turks have
nothing we are living outside in
terrible conditions while syrians have
tons aren't we human beings too
the Turkish Ministry of Defense has more
than 40 000 syrians have returned to
their country in the past weeks
many others here are also finding it
difficult to survive in a disaster area
and they're considering other options
Ibrahim Ali is a Syrian journalist he
says he fears the lead-up to turkey's
presidential elections in May could
increase hostile sentiment towards
syrians in the country some like special
like from the right like side of flight
parties considering as like actually
more
loyal to other parties which is make it
like very difficult for us syrians and
if you are trying like to do like a
little survey around between civilians
they know nothing about policy or like
politic like here they're just like
trying to leave
millions of syrians have come to Turkey
to escape the war in their Nation now
they've lost everything they had once
again and have to survive in a country
that is not their own
turkey